the Joe Rogan experience the other thing
about getting older is you get sort
faster I had ever such a stupid thing I
had to have a wrestling match with my
jeans don't ask together I couldn't get
him off and why are you show only show
why don't you get stretchy jeans no but
it was part of the comedy you know oh
that you couldn't move good new jeans
yeah guys I want to give away the
episode of school do you know you can
have to wait oh yeah I tied to my leg
aware no sir as you know cuz he's unruly
and he's always wanting to get in the
feed bucket you know that wasn't part of
the joke dose on your hog no but I do
that like 10 50 takes and well I was
sore the next day oh yeah ever sure I
was sore the next Jebb Matt's from
comedy I was sore from physical comedy
yesterday
that's some serious physical comedy and
that that is a point that I've I've
heard before and I don't know if this is
true but many people have told me and
this was like this long-standing thing
that you know Chevy Chase is kind of
known as a grumpy guy yeah they said
that Chevy Chase did so many pratfalls
that he's in pain all the time that's it
that's interesting just stop and think
about all the times you saw Chevy Chase
fall down in movies and in TV shows and
one of the things that happens obviously
to older athletes that play football or
combat sports or boxing is getting beat
up like that getting slammed around like
that they got bad backs they get
headaches they get a little bit don't
feel good you're always now yeah you
know especially the athletes get the
PTSD but what what you're seeing with
him it very well could be that that guy
hurt his body real bad doing pratfalls
Buster Keaton who's like the very first
ever stuntman who did crazy [ __ ] man if
your watch like some old Buster Keaton
films the stunts that that guy did back
when he couldn't fake any like nuts but
I was always getting peed up his body
was [ __ ] up man yeah let's hear Chevy
Chase falling down bro I got news for
you oh this is all legit and he fell a
lot man
constantly he was like almost like a Tom
Green type character but now so yeah
yeah but also a brilliant actor and
comedian so he fell all the [ __ ] time
so I'm guessing as a person who's fallen
a bunch of times yeah that guy's
probably in pain a lot like all the time
but people always say Chevy Chase is so
grumpy yeah maybe he's just [ __ ] in
pain oh yeah maybe just doesn't feel
good how do you can't feel there's no
way dude that's just a few he fell on
Saturday live all the time he fell
didn't he fall in Fletch
remember that cop movie actually
improved I think he feels absolutely
think a lot of things bro you fell
through everything so for me some of
them might have a stuntman I was boxing
so much and what I would do is I would
just get in the ring and I would just
start hitting mitts kind of light and
fanned by light I mean you know I don't
know 30% and then in about a minute I'm
trying I'm going full because I'm warmed
up I'm Rob I feel great yeah and a guy
who is a trainer walk by he said he's to
be a pro football player and and now he
trains a lot of pro athletes and he
knows his [ __ ] and he walked by and he
goes he looks at me and he goes think
Chris Camacho Chris lifts the man goes
he's not warming up again huh
got his fifties cool just going at it
huh he just left amazing comment yeah
that's all he said he knew but he knew
and sure enough sure enough I'm still
now I have mailed a box and I don't know
three months dude because I [ __ ]
myself up
[Applause]